in this problem a farmer is using a 1T
diameter well to irrigate a field before
the Well's pump is activated the petric
surface of the water in the irrigation
well is 20 ft below the ground
surface after the pump reaches
equilibrium at a flow rate of 0.5 cubic
feet per second the draw Downs in each
of the wells are given as
follows the irrigation well draw down is
10 ft
the observation well number one draw
down is 9.6 ft and the observation well
number two draw down is 7.5
ft what is the transmissivity in square
feet per second of the confined
aquafer so we can start this problem by
searching in the manual for the word
transmissivity the second instance of
this word will take you to page 419 for
the section on confined
aquifers this is the section we want
since we can see that we have a confined
aquifer in this problem the equation
that transmissivity is in
here is the uniform flow or theum
equation let's write it
out the theum equation or the uniform
flow equation is given as Q = 2 pi t
time the quantity of H2 - H1 over the
natural log of r2/
R1 T is going to be equal to the
transmissivity which is also equal to K
* B where B is the thickness of the
confined
aquafer and K is the permeability of the
aquifer H1 and H2 are the heights of the
petric
surface above the bottom of the
aquifer and R1 and R2 are the radi from
the pumping
well note that both terms H1 and H2 are
noted to be the heights of the petric
surface above the bottom of the
aquifer however our problem only
provides us with the draw Downs of the
wells after pumping
begins so our first step will be to
calculate H1 and
H2 the problem mentions that the
irrigation well has a petric surface of
20 ft below the ground surface before
the pump turns on we can use this number
to establish our reference point or our
datam it also mentions that the
irrigation well has a draw down of 10 ft
after the pump turns on but this is not
needed for our
calculations however we can quick
quickly do this to help show the cone of
depression that forms when the well is
pumping you wouldn't need to do it on
the exam to solve this
problem to find our datm or our
reference point first we have to sum up
the 35 ft from the impermeable layer
plus the 5 ft from the confined
aquifer then we have to subtract
the petric surface of the water in the
irrigation
well before the pump is turned
on that will be the initial depth of
water in the
well now that we have our datm or our
reference point from the ground up we
can subtract the given draw Downs
provided for each observation well to
find the heights of the petric surface
above the ground once these values are
found we have all of the information we
need to solve for transmissivity in the
theme
equation the H value or height of the
irrigation well which we don't need but
can calculate will
be the 20t reference point minus the 10t
draw down giving us an H of 10
ft H1 or the height of the water in the
nearest observation well observation
well one after pumping begins is going
to be found by taking our reference
point of 20 ft and subtracting the 9.6
ft draw down from it giving us 10.4
ft similarly the height of the
observation well 2 after pumping begins
is going to be the 20ft reference point
minus the 7.5 ft draw down giving us
12.5 ft once these values are found we
have all of the information we need to
solve for transmissivity in the the
equation filling in our terms we can see
that Q = 0.5 cubic feet per second = 2
piun * T which is what we're solving for
H2 will be 12.5 H1 is
10.4 over Radius 2 equal to 87 ft and
radius 1 equal to 37 ft
and we can see that our final answer for
transmissivity is equal to
0.032 ft per
second in summary this question requires
the
following knowing to use the theum
equation for confined
aquafers understanding that draw down
values are not terms H1 and H2 directly
but that they can be used to solve for
those
terms and we also have to not mix up our
H1 and H2 or our R1 and R2
terms if you can do those things you
should be able to solve this problem